[Music]
many children abused by members of the
catholic church were not believed or
listened to for years some were even
accused of contributing to what had
happened to them among those victims
olivier savignac abused by a priest when
he was thirteen
yes the report is an earthquake yes it's
a hurricane yes it's a tsunami and it
has to be a tsunami because today when
we see the numbers it's so damning that
no one can be in denial both within the
catholic church and the whole of society
the roman catholic church betrayed the
trust of the young and vulnerable on a
devastating scale
the conclusion of a two and a half year
investigation into clerical child abuse
carried out by 3 000 suspected
pedophiles in the french church
in the french population now aged 18 and
over 216 000 plus or minus 50 000 were
sexually assaulted by clerics priests or
nuns as minors
and when lay members of the church such
as teachers at catholic schools are
included the number of child victims
climbs to 330 000 over the seven decade
period
a major point that must bend the line is
that until the early 2000s there was a
deep total and even crawling difference
for years
recent scandals have decimated the
church's credibility at a time of
dwindling attendances
last year defrocked french catholic
priest bernard prenath was sentenced to
five years in jail for abusing scouts in
his care several decades ago
the case also led to the resignation of
his superior the archbishop of lyon
philly barbara accused of covering up
the abuse
the scandal in france is the latest to
hit the catholic church rocked by abuse
scandals around the world
in june pope francis said the church
abuse crisis was a worldwide catastrophe
this year he issued an extensive
revision of church law insisting bishops
take robust action against clerical
abuse
the french church said in march it would
propose some form of financial aid to
the victims but campaigners have been
left asking how it's possible to put a
price on suffering
neve barker al-jazeera
well now joining us from philadelphia in
the united states is massimo fagioli he
is a professor of historical theology at
villanova university professor thank you
for joining us i note that this
commission was instigated by the bishops
themselves but that was obviously after
so many decades of pushing aside even
disregarding victims so what actually
changed
what has changed is that in the catholic
church worldwide uh things started to
change in 2010
when pope benedict was pope and a wave
of allegations came from germany and a
further step was taken when pope francis
was elected
because
a
wave of other investigations were
disclosed in australia in the united
states uh
in in germany again so this is part of
an entirely
new phase in the history of the catholic
church's sexual crisis
well pope francis has been trying to
reform the church from within since he
took over how do you think these
revelations are going over with him
beyond his expression of sorrow do you
think there's more action being taken
behind the scenes
the problem that devantegan faces is
that there is so far in the vatican a
refusal
or denial to address systemic issues
that have to do with the priestly
ministry
of
of uh of the priests uh celibacy uh and
the monarchical structure of the church
on other issues
action has been swift and indecisive
what needs to be done and this is
something this report acknowledges and
demands uh is a series of steps in
dismantling the hierarchical structure
of the church as a monopoly
on the control of uh
of
of everything that moves
either the church this is something on
which pope francis has been so far very
cautious or reluctant even
well you spoke about action being taken
there are you confident that the church
itself will take action against
perpetrators who are still alive i see
there are more than 40 cases that are
too old for other authorities to
prosecute so will the church actually do
something
the problem is that or our uh hope is
that this solution right now is not any
more in hands of the church it's much
more than in the past in the hands of
public opinion of the press
uh of justice of of of of the police
system so that's why we are in the new
face because whatever the church does
internally it is regularly overcome
and surpassed by
as a series of actions that have taken
places already outside of the church and
the catholic church is still on the
defensive
and in some sense
what the church can do uh about the past
is not the most important question is
what the church will let the justice
system
investigating commissions to do
you mentioned that pope francis is up
against quite a lot of um i guess
critique within the church in order to
try to change things from within do you
see that shifting at all you mentioned
public opinion there has public opinion
actually changed the way the church sees
itself
the public opinion has changed in the
sense that in the last few years
it has become evident that there is no
possible
solution to this exhibit crisis without
thinking and discussing
about the form of priestly ministry
which means celibacy
which means vertical hierarchy
that's something that has changed
already in the in in the catholic church
made
of laypeople it still struggles to
become accepted
among bishops
in the vatican but this is not something
that can be stopped i think
and this is a conversation that has
started already if one looks at germany
what's happening there this is a
conversation that has started already
massimo faggioli there a professor of
the of historical theology at villanova
university great to get your thoughts
and insight on al jazeera thank you for
joining us professor
thank you